I'm gonna start with Emma because I just
thought it was fabulous and kind of just
talk about Peele Travis Emma I assume
when you were off at this role you would
think well how could I not take this yes
I know yes absolutely
how could I know take this we're all all
of us at my age going over there are no
roles ruin at all and then one of the
best roles were ever played come sailing
along courtesy of my fine and
extraordinary friend Kelly Marcel this
is the most brilliant writer I mean it
was one of those read the first page to
go I mean I mean yes okay I'll do it
you don't have to pay me they did they
did they decision but they paid me in
chocolates and stuffed toys delighted
they paid you let me just move over to
Tom Hanks
you can't keep you away from London Tom
you know you were here for the beginning
you here for the closing I think that's
a record was there obviously begin a
sleeping bag behind a tea shop by the
serpentine in Hyde Park for the last
week and a half here we host that joke
five minutes it is worked really well
I'm sorry I interrupted your fascinating
question was there any sense of
trepidation for you in playing someone
like Walt Disney does he seem to you
like the kind of man that would
experience trepidation in approaching a
role
sorry
[Laughter]
a question I swear to god I'm not there
there was a responsibility let me put it
that way
which is different than trepidation
there was it's without a doubt it's a
substantial gauntlet to throw down
I grew up were you Walt Disney was
ubiquitous in our lives is the Uncle Sam
and Smokey the Bear and the combination
of the President of the United States
and Mickey Mouse himself so I felt as
though there was going to be a quite a
distance ago and I had not a clue as to
to where to begin outside my own
memories and that led to a substantial
there's a lot of video out there there's
a lot of audio that you can listen to
unfortunately it's mostly Walt Disney
performing as Walt Disney so when you
can find those moments where we're just
talking in as natural cadence about
something other than the new exciting
realm of Tomorrowland which we'll be
opening and is it that that was worth
its weight in gold and I had some access
to that thanks to Diane Miller Disney
his daughter and the fabulous museum
that she was established in San
Francisco okay thank you John Lee
Hancock next to me how did you how did
you come to be introduced to this to
this project and once you saw it did you
think it was a no-brainer I I was trying
to set up another movie I do adult
dramas and so it takes about 10 years to
get them made usually so I was trying to
get another one set up that had fallen
apart several times and the script came
across the desk for me to read and I was
told it was quite good and I knew that
it was you know about the behind the
scenes the making of Mary Poppins and I
thought well I like Mary Poppins I'm not
somebody that watches it every year so
I'm probably not the right person for
this and eventually my agent told me
that I should definitely read it
if only for the pleasure of having done
so and I picked it up and was just
enthralled again with Kelly's words and
I felt like even though I'm you know a
Texas guy from a refinery town I felt
inside the store
and it was one that I desperately wanted
to tell that I had to get the job so I
had to go in and and you know pitch my
take on it talk about the movie and and
thankfully met Alison Owen there in that
meeting and I got hired I don't know how
but thank God I'm going to move to
Alison next Alison I can't see you I'll
ask you this question without looking at
you you're such a long way away there's
there's obviously a problem in making a
movie about a Disney film with Disney
songs I've had a studio about a
corporation did you did you expect a lot
of problems from Disney and were they
thought coming I think Kelly and I
didn't know quite when we were
developing the project and and certainly
from you know from its inception there
were there was a question about well how
much of this of the clips of the songs
do we use how much intellectual property
rights are we going to play fast and
loose with hear and Kelly at one time
was that you know worldwide tiptoe round
them am I trying to use as little as
possible or do we just throw caution to
the winds and make the best story that
we can and I think she was steering me
in a certain direction let's just let's
just go for it and there are they there
they're either going to let us do it in
which case we might as well make it the
best it possibly can be
or they'll shut us down in which case it
doesn't matter how much all three years
so Kelly sets out just trying to write
the best trip she could and use all the
material and then we had a certain
strategy and in terms of approaching
Disney and lucky for us the right people
were sitting at the right desks and then
the right chairs that
and I think Mary Poppins was blowing the
wind in the right direction and I think
that with favor and Disney have
supported this project and been
absolutely smart and intelligent in
their approach and in terms of letting
us do the right thing but there may be a
better story okay
so Kelly was it and it was your instinct
to go for broke as well was it rather
than try and be cautious and try and
anticipate roadblocks yeah absolutely I
really felt like you couldn't tell a
story about the making of Mary Poppins
without losing the songs and using Walt
Disney and you know just really throwing
it all at the script I would be
disappointed if I went see that film and
didn't get to have a little sing-along
so we I think we were we knew that
that's what we were gonna do from day
one and I think if Allison hadn't said
just go for it not sure I would have
known how to write it or know what to do
with it it was mine yeah definitely my
instinct to go mad okay good
Colin it seems that you know it's almost
like you were in a different movie half
the time there sounds like a big insult
but I know that it wasn't please carry
on being hopeful again there's a
foreground story and and and there's a
back story which of course is the the
story of mr. banks and it seems to me
it's just very different from any role
I've seen you played it sort of feel
like a departure for you um anytime you
kind of step into the the fiction of
another person's skin and you go from
objectively perusing the script on the
character's life into being a subject of
the story it's a departure like it truly
is but this was I suppose if I was to
look back at the chronology stuff that I
taught it tells feel a little bit more
unique and I think more than more than
nothing about the characters that's
about the sensibility and the
sensitivity of the whole film just in
reading is you know sometimes you read
things and you put them down and you get
very unethical about them and you think
about the dialogue you think about the
situation in the character
and you look at the whole story as a
narrative this defied any kind of
analysis
it was just moving from start to finish
and funny that turns so I loved the
character but even more than the
character because through the years I
just seem you know I feel that it's it's
really nice to be part of things that
work and things that affect people and
so that the whole becomes greater you
know then the parts that make it feeling
that seem that becomes more apparent to
me to the years so I was delighted for
it like Emma I'd mean I never did read
the first page because if it came down
and then we heard my voice voiceovers
like yes it's my film anyone who wants
to the audience has any of you seen the
film Mary Poppins since you made this
since you made saving mr. banks and does
it feel different now you understand the
sort of back story of it the first night
we were all together in LA Cole had us
all over his gaff and showed the showed
Mary Poppins that's the last time I saw
it actually and we all sat there
marveling at it and going oh my God look
at this bit and I've forgotten that bit
and then oh my god it's so wrong in prep
Kelly Kelly and I went through how many
times scene by scene just just saying is
there some little twinkle we can put in
this yeah people that are real fans of
the movie that won't obstruct the plot
or the tone of the theme just little
nuggets for people that are big fans and
so there they're a bunch of them in
there yeah that's quite a few it was
lovely never for Colin I thought the
performance he gave particularly the
young attorney Rose but it was immensely
moving and basically not father-daughter
chemistry I just wonder if you've got to
say about how you managed to get that do
you talk with her first or initial
experience with filming with that
custard creams and a cattle rod and I
vacillated between both a hug punishment
she wasn't she was incredible I mean I
don't know how many actors or actresses
are just small female human beings that
John Lee and and Alison may have met in
Los Angeles but I know they met many and
when they went over to Australia to
research where Travis coffin and the
family were from they saw a lot of young
girls there as well and I believe you
went through was quite an ordeal to get
her legal papers to work wasn't it but
it was worth every single phone call and
every single bit of sweat because she
was phenomenal and to work with her was
just really easy she was there with her
twin brother Max and her parents were
over and you know our section of the
film was was such a it was such a
pleasure that they shot on chronology
and they blocked it off so it was two
weeks so very much did it feel like a
film in and of itself so for two weeks
who went to a ranch about 350 acres bed
an hour and a half drive north of Los
Angeles scorched earth yellow grass bent
over and they built a lovely wooden
house on top of this bluff and it was
just me and Ruth and the girls and six
chickens and one horse and happy days
man you know and I was all there on the
page as well that's all there it's a
general question about acting linked to
feel how much inputs you like a writer
to have when you're playing and in a
film that's been written based on the
book and told me in particular to your
production side B I mean do you really
like the writer to get involved in the
script writing or do you like them to
just a hangover well in this case is now
a hired gun we I did say that didn't
appear in the script and we had meetings
in which we went over I did have
questions like there was some
Americanisms that I think needed to be
put in and some things that I discovered
that Walt had had a tendency to say an
imagery that he used but that was all
okay we treated this I think we could
all agree like the Gutenberg Bible we
according to and I there are types of
films that define themselves and that
was I think always going to be the
requirement for making this movie it was
extremely well constructed beautifully
knit sweater and I wasn't about to start
pulling a pulling a thread loose and
have it all fall apart it's miserable
going onto a film with a script that's
not ready you know really I mean barry
sonnenfeld will tell you we didn't have
a third act of men in black until he
started filming without a third act I
don't understand how to work like that
I finished films where the script still
isn't ready you know it was so
beautifully written it didn't I added
one line and it's brilliant oh yeah they
were all absolutely amazingly true to
the text it was it was such an
incredible experience actually to have
everyone just be so true to the script
that's all John as well
okay gentlemen here a question for Emma
first of all congratulations on a
terrific performance you have me in
tears at the end you have me some
tissues thus I say I've given your
stellar reputation as someone that
everyone says they love working with how
did you kind of get into the mindset of
a woman at one point even says I won't
have read in the film the height of
awkwardness I just let out my inner
prickly pear was my true self hide that
for effect you know because you get on
whether people give you more stuff so I
just just let it all hang out and
actually I've got a 10 you it's such a
relief to be rude really without any
repercussions whatsoever
you know say I don't can you imagine it
I don't want to go to your [ __ ] press
conference because I'm bored with them
or I don't want to come out to your
birthday party because my I mean if you
could just come out with these things
and she did she said what she meant she
just said it I'm nine do that sometimes
and get into terrible trouble but and
probably will now but that was what was
so great I feel she has been here hi
guys I really loved the film great job
and my question is for all the actors if
you had the opportunity to ask the
characters you were playing one thing
what would you ask them to get into the
mindset of that card to make sure you
played them as correctly as possible
yeah can you repeat what you just asked
why did you why don't you leave them
quicker No
question it's a good question
go on you next time
and thus the press conference came to a
sorry it's gonna fill me with
self-loathing later on you know the
knockin was such a brilliant question
those relations for that how about if we
can tell the other person what we would
ask what I respect the idea and it's a
good idea please Kelly write something
we can I have my part
we're not leaving this room later let's
talk to this lady Oh
this question is probably for Emma
you did you created your own sort of
Mary Poppins at some point it called
nanny mcphee so how how influenced were
you I mean - how did you know the story
behind Mary Poppins the book and how do
you already research that no no not at
all no my husband did point out to me
this way said you think it's interesting
that you created a magical nanny and
then you've played someone who's created
a magical Nonis you suppose it behind
every magical man is a cantankerous
opinionated outback you know someone you
wish you could be certainly I wish I
could be like that and and I think that
with with Walton the mouse and Pam and
her her nanny
there's certainly these are characters
that have created out of the soul of
that person when the soul was very
vulnerable and emergent as it were so
that's what gives them their power their
staying power and she said that she
didn't invent Mary Poppins that her
marathon was just arrived and I think
that most writers of genius would say
the same thing no Mozart said my muse
I didn't write it it just arrived in me
there's no even in the most cantankerous
writer says a generosity of spirit about
where these innocent these things come
from and of course they're not going to
come unless you sit at the writing table
with your pen that's the discipline but
if you do that then then it's like Field
of Dreams you know if you sit there it
will come and and sometimes it's in a
form that will survive any number of
cultural interpretations and
reinterpretations and that's what's so
interesting about about this as a movie
about two cultures coming together
clashing over this one iconic creation
when you were beginning of your careers
or before that what kind of breezes
where you had before coming into this
dream world if you have and if it was
connected I had no dreams at all I was
just trying to you know make Utica I'm
just trying to get some other job other
than the one I had you know that it's
that's not unlike what what Walt Disney
did you know anybody started drawing he
was drawing out in the in the
disconnected garage from his house in
Kansas City and he just had the art
supplies and he was just banging out
stuff that came into his head hoping
that he might be able to sell them for
$5 a piece I relate to that there's no
clue as to where any of this stuff will
take you I was hoping to you know make a
little bit more than that nothing
because I thought that this is just a
job that you volunteer for and if you're
good enough at it they'll ask you to
play something else and maybe they'll
make you pay you fifty bucks a week but
this concept of having dreams when
you're young and always having your eye
on the day I could never understand that
I didn't
a single dream in my head I kind of
operated like the Communists you know I
had like a hey if I build a decent
tractor maybe I can build another
tractor it's like I didn't even have a
five-year plan I was just stumbling
around Tom Hanks accomplice thank you a
lot of the meetings obviously were
recorded and indeed Travis and Disney
were recorded a lot there's a lot of
factual information about everyone evil
about some of these people involved so
how much creative license can any of you
take with the characters with the story
and indeed with the people who aren't so
well documented as well movie makers
yeah nice and steady if you're artists I
mean we're not documentarians
so you have to surely I mean yeah I mean
job one is for it to be entertaining and
hopefully moving and you have all that
information about real characters you
have to condense it you have to find an
order for it I don't think anybody would
want to watch a movie of the 39 hours
spent in the rehearsal room that would
be like a Warhol film or something but
there I'm sure there were days they were
utterly boring in there so I think when
you've got Kelly Marcel to be able to
parse through everything and find the
stuff that's entertaining and how had it
somehow congeal in a way where the
matically it's true and tonally it's
true that's job one I think and with her
P L Travers had this theory later on in
her life that women's lives divided into
three main part
NIMS mother and Crone and it's great
because it's very interesting and very
something very true about it and we
wanted to put a part of each part into
this incarnation of her so that rather
than me playing someone who was a chance
that would have driven us all and the
audience screaming out into the night so
looting carts from when she was a mother
when she was a name when she was acting
you know her sexuality that's creative
license I suppose you're taking bits and
folding them back into this period of
time which after all is not very long to
spend with a very complicated character
two hours you know to the I suppose
that's creative license as well and
share your memories of watching mobile
for the first time to be part of the
over-tighten all gamers come loose uh
yeah I used to watch it pretty much
every Christmas and so I'm a minor
inside out learning flying kind of a
song one of them so yeah it was big part
of growing up you haven't watched it
much simply watched a Collins
singer since the movie I'm intrigued to
see it to see if I say it differently
she was I think I was it was re-released
I didn't see it in his first go around
and thing a sudden re-release and I was
probably taken to her life but the Mary
Poppins step in time the Chimney Sweeps
dance I remember I just thought that was
I remember that when the smoke turns
into a ladder you know the smoke tons of
distance
you remember that this is just moments
you just go as a child I wanted that to
be possible
so I really wanted that and I was so in
love with obsessing over everlasting
gobstoppers from the wonka factory -
yeah it's kind of like a Beatles Rolling
Stones question where you were Mary
Poppins fella or Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory fellas Willy Wonka
Chocolate Factory
not that you can nothing there's any
particular perfect time for anyone to
see it but I think Willy Wonka was my
Christmas film yeah yeah they only know
Roald Dahl hated it but but you know
yeah Stephen King hated The Shining
they're very different mediums I get why
writer
my hey
[Laughter]
where is that Butler dick was amazing I
was just explaining to someone earlier
actually that after we met him we did an
entirely new horse of the script because
his mannerisms are enormous I mean he's
the biggest jolliest fellow you could
ever meet he's literally like a cartoon
character he's just incredibly wonderful
and meeting him was kind of a beautiful
experience we came in and he was crying
because she had ruined his life I mean
he he really was very bitter and twisted
about what went on in those rooms with P
L Travers and when we went to see him he
was saying to John Allison and I crying
his eyes out going I didn't know that
she had that childhood and now I can
forgive her and now I feel okay so it's
been quite a cathartic experience for
dick and he played all of the Mary
Poppins songs for us and we all just
cried for an hour yeah but no I mean it
was one of the most joyous things
actually I think was was having Richard
and and Liz along for the experience to
watch two people have to watch two
people watching moments from their lives
being reconstructed in front of them and
and weeping and holding each other's
hands was incredibly moving
really really wonderful them and Richard
was an incredible asset to experiment
start but both yeah because if it's
enthusiasm his support his anecdotes and
what he meant to Disney his support when
we went into Disney with Disney was
absolutely invaluable cuz he's a very
special Disney person and the fact that
he'd taken us under our wing and he
loved what we've done with what we had
done and and felt that it conveyed the
truth and was credible and should be
told
yeah and as an advisor on the film he
was he was there with this area which
was really invaluable I've got one last
question because we have to wrap up in a
second the question is for John how do
you want this film to be viewed as an
entertainment as something that's
something we'll said but will surprise
people will inform people oh gosh what
do you want for it well that's a tough
one you you want all the above I mean
you make a movie everybody says you make
movie movies for everybody else but I
mean ultimately it's a year and a half
to two years of your life it's a
marriage not a date
you have to make it for yourself first
and foremost and you hope that other
people enjoy and and see what you saw in
it and what you continue to see in it so
I'm just be very happy for people to see
the movie that we've all worked so hard
on you know and hopefully they enjoy it
for whatever reasons and whatever people
glean from that good on you I hope thank
you
you